the idea for this class is very much to
invite the members to give us a game to
look and analyze for yourselves so first
of all do any much didn't yes you have
it and you were white or black okay
Gabriel and you played wow very strong
player Petros
Carrie cutter genious Guiness it's very
nice Greek name mispronounced it in the
super team championship played last year
you were white and you opened b4 aka the
orangutan variation b4 c6 Bishop b2 now
I'm not a big experienced player on the
black side of the orangutan I played it
a little bit with white mostly in blitz
I don't think I ever played it in
tournament play but this move strikes me
as premature that is to say really yeah
bringing out the Queen so early in the
opening like that okay well obviously
his intention is to capture the pawn all
right so you defended the pawn makes
sense to me a3 and then he played the
move
a5 okay
so this is it so now you have a question
that you need to ask yourself how are
you going to defend the pawn on b4
you went III you went III ignoring his
threat for the moment he took the pawn
on before and you shot out with your
Bishop to d4 and black fell for a trick
I think yeah okay so what what what
white is thinking is that if he had
recaptured right away then after trade
on a one black wanted to win the pawn on
d4 so if the Queen moves to a5 as we've
seen in trades itself on a1 we think
Queen c1 2 B 2 will chase the rook away
and that will be inadequate black has
missed a trick black played the move c5
well of course I mean he took the pawn
on d4 to win the pond and the only way
to keep the Faunus to play c5 but now
white said thank you very much I will
take the pawn on c5 Bishop takes e5 and
now Queen went across to f6 attacking
the rook on a1 gosh this is a weird
situation now you played Bishop d4 and
d5 and it got weird I mean it's weird
from the start right I mean so thank you
for the game I'm a that's just like but
maybe there was something also to be
said for d4 here just because
pardon me sorry say that again Gabriel I
missed right so I'm thinking that d4 to
block the threat now if black for
argument's sake plays a move like d6 or
b6 you're just wanting to play Bishop
takes b4 and then your pawn ahead and if
black plays a move like knight c6 then
after Knight d2 well again you're
threatening to take this pawn on d4 and
I don't know in case of trades seems to
me that after all of these trades
White's got the edge
I mean his pawn structure looks a little
bit nicer than this isolated pawn over
here and the bishops actually doing
pretty good you're going to go Knight f3
if he plays a six you can mess up his
opportunity to castle so I think I would
have gone for d4 at this point
you played a reasonable move you played
Bishop d4 and new variation B 5 and oh I
don't like this move you played Bishop
b2 and that looks like a lost tempo to
me from my point of view if I were white
I would want to take on b4 and resolve
this tension like ASAP so in the game
you have retreated your Bishop to b2
when maybe or but another way I
certainly would have taken on b4 right
away so this would have probably
provoked black to trade the rooks and
now since black is upon down you
probably take and you know you can you
can decide for yourself whether you
think white is good or better or
what-have-you
I like White's position here I think
like white is doing pretty good
in the first place there's a square d5
so the moves Knight c3 to defy start to
be attractive in the second place thanks
to the Queen being a little bit
misplaced on f6 putting pressure on this
pawn on e5 starts to be attractive maybe
f4 right away it's a little bit risky
because your King but okay he can't take
the rook yeah there you go
but in in this case the bishop on anyone
looks very nice right it's on the long
diagonal yeah okay you guys having a
good time huh so here I didn't like the
move you've played you've played Bishop
b2 let's see oops sorry
Bishop b2 okay this is an this is the
new main light
okay so Bishop b2 knight c6 Knight f3 so
far everything's still okay
d5 Bishop b5 very nice pinning like this
Bishop g4 let me just pause then we just
pause here for a second okay I like your
move h3 I was just wondering about
something else now mmm takes takes takes
takes takes takes takes nothing okay no
okay
h3 so you're breaking the pin Bishop f3
Queen f3 Queen f3 g f3 I still give you
an edge f6 okay
now you made a move rook g1 okay that's
a3 a4 now for white mm-hmm okay so first
quick question for the class just again
and get a feel for who likes White's
position who likes blacks position who
thinks it's even so mum most of the
players are like whites position and I
do too I like whites position for a
couple of reasons the first reason is I
like the two bishops that's simple I
like whites Bishop on b5 I think it's a
very good piece second thing is at the
moment I don't think that this pawn on
b7 is a weakness but it could easily
become a weakness for black the other
thing I actually like is I do like even
though these pawns are doubled I
actually like White's pawn structure
because I think that if white steps up
with this King into the center
kingi - it's going to be real real slate
safe kind of kind of like in a pocket a
zone of protection yeah
Gabriel you've gone for rook g1 and
here's why I'm not really a big fan of
that move first of all when you know and
my kind of thinking is is I'm I'm going
to kind of laser-like lock in on a
weakness that my opponent has okay so if
my opponent has weakness so in this
position
I'm looking at the at the structure and
I'm thinking to myself okay if I take
this pawn he'll trade rooks takes and
then because I've initiated this capture
he's going to recapture bishop takes
before so I can actually wait
I would rather allow black to capture me
and then develop me so I want to make a
useful waiting move you came up with the
move rook g1 and the way I look at that
move is that you're not really attacking
the key weakness to my mind this pawn on
on a4 would be the weakness so what I
might do is I might play to move King e2
right so let's just say for argument's
sake king of seven then let's go a let
me just put it on the board sorry let me
go King II - okay
now let's just say for argument's sake
king of seven black makes a useful move
he gets his King out of the pin trade
trade yay trade yay night huh oops sorry
Knight comes out Knight defends rook
rook b1 and Knight d5 is also possible
so maybe Knight takes d5 a Julian wimpy
with the tactical Flair
and now you gotta decide well again the
whole point of my king e to useful move
is I was I'm dreaming of the opportunity
to play rook b1 and and go after this
week pawn and whether I do it with 95 a
rook the rook e1 right away
I was thinking that my King needed to
make room for the rook so we go back for
a moment because obviously we messed it
up for black so let's say King E - let's
give black another move instead ah
that's a good move I don't know let's
say Knight h6 new variation
let's take rip trades Bishop trades
Bishop takes on d4 Knight comes to c3
and my mind's eye I'm thinking that if I
can bring my room to be one that I'm
going to start to attack target the pawn
on b2 of course his pawn on d5 is
hanging and black may be obliged to give
up yet another his other Bishop and go
into defense mode the problem that I
have with your move rook g1 is oops is
this is actually a very logical move
from the perspective that you have the
half-open G file put a rook on the
half-open G file pressure g7 the problem
with this move is that if what if black
adequately defends the pawn on g7 in
other words if if the pawn on g7 turns
out not to be a weakness then maybe the
move of g1 is misplaced all right
you have played after King of 7 you you
made the decision to trade trade trade
Oh army King f7 good and now we're back
to our situation I think I would have
played King e 2
at this point I think that the King is
just simply much better on e to then on
the e1 square so I would have to say
that this it move a takes b4 helps black
it's more helpful to black than to white
did you consider the Mookie knee to by
the way no yeah I mean who voluntarily
moves your king well I do that you know
like okay okay five hands got raised on
that one silly question okay but you do
recognize that the king is in kind of a
comfort zone here right I mean
everything is really nice nice the other
thing is is it's not so easy
if black puts his knight on East seven
he's kind of interfering with his
bishops control if black moves his
bishop then you've got the same position
only a tempo more and your King would
probably be happy on e to another just
funny
besides the move a b4 and Keeney - was
there another move that you would
consider it I can see one other move
that I would have been attracted to
here's the move that I would have been
attracted to I would probably rejected
it in favor of kini - but the other move
that I'm attracted to is again you know
I'm always looking at the Trump's in my
hand and I'm trying to say to myself
okay
what's good about my position well
that's not exactly my ace in the hole
like kind of like the three of clubs
okay
but the ace I do have is this Bishop on
b5 and it would be really cool if I
could play the move Bishop c4 because it
would be a check and it would mess up my
opponent so well the so the movie for I
might find attractive but I would reject
efore because I I don't want to meet 94
but another move I would find very
attractive here for white is c4 okay so
I think once you see the move c4 and
it's played in front of you
you kind of start to say yeah that move
has a logic right first of all if it's
my turn I take upon life is good
second of all if you take my pawn I've
got a check and my ace my LightSquared
Bishop is looking pretty good in that
check if you take on pass ah okay I mean
I can live with that too Knight takes c3
develops with the tempo against the pawn
on d5 and then there are ideas like
Julian just showed that in case of 95 95
95 Bishop c4 so the move c4 also has a
logic so I like king e2 best rub g1 not
so happy King f7 takes okay let's see
what happened after takes a takes b4
okay just a second he takes b4 where am
I
hate that ripped xa1 bishop takes a
one-night takes b4 ooh and you have an
issue the issue you have is what are you
going to do about the pawn on c2 you did
nothing you played Knight c3 which is
when did your hatred of pawns first
manifest are you young yeah I'm treating
them badly
uh I I really value okay okay understood
I would have probably developed my
knight to a three okay so I would have
probably played my knight to a three and
my king - II - and then you know because
I love my kids place played c4 yeah or
like 93 King e2 rook e1 c3 drive the
knight back I like you played 1993 and I
think that this is simply too -
enterprising and remarkably enough he
did not he did not capture the pawn I
find that amazing he played the move d4
so okay d4 whoa now things got weird you
played you played a strange order of
moves you played 95 Knight takes too
Bishop c4 when I think everybody would
have played Bishop c4 check right I mean
you are just explaining a moment ago
that you had hope for slash anticipated
that after Knight takes e to check King
e2 Knight takes a one rook takes a one
in your mind's eye and I think that's
correct
you saw that not only was the d5 pawn
hanging but your rook could come down
and recapture the pawn and in the
meantime it you know he's got three and
a half PP pieces on the Kings side that
he has to deal with so you had
anticipated this variation and when your
opponent played d4
you mix something up here because you
have played again in the game you've
played Knight d5 and after Knight takes
d5 Bishop here night here in order to
win your knight back you had to play the
movie four and then this guy's a little
bit unhappy right and also you now your
pawn structure especially your double
pawns start to look a little bit bad
okay but had you played properly had you
played Bishop you know one of the things
that I really had a problem with was
when I was starting is if there was a
check in the position I was going for it
right and so you had to kind of stop
yourself from making a check every
opportunity you get and just ask
yourself well who would benefit more
from the check but in this particular
case white stands to benefit a lot more
because there's only two squares to go
you would love your opponent to go like
blindly and the e7 which steps in front
of the bishop and steals a square for a
knight so the King would have to go back
and if you start thinking in terms of
like why did you put your rook on G
one will you put your rook on g12 target
this pawn on g7 so you're driving away a
defender so from all perspectives
the check is great right I mean yeah and
even now right Julian with the tactical
I the has pointed out that in case of 94
Knight takes e to king e 2 after Knight
takes a one you could recapture what you
Gabriel had in mind of activating your
rub but what Julian pointing out is that
white also has another option of Bishop
tanks so that in case of rook takes to
take on f6 now that's a judgment call
whether or not you want to win two
pieces for a run here I'd be a little
bit concerned that that yeah yeah beep
on is a beep on might might might might
go into overdrive and I'd be a little
bit I'd be a little bit worried about
that but in any case Bishop c4 check you
know you
on I think the other idea because the I
my the night is still cap cross with you
so I figured this course of the night -
in fact I was kind of it
yeah I'm realizing
your your pawn structure but Bishop c4
check boy that sure looks like an
attractive move to me I mean I would
have most certainly tried it and on also
just to finish that one line because I
didn't go down the pathway that I'd
hoped to which was Bishop c4 check King
e8 I like this move 95 a new variation
because even though you have lost your
pond on c2 naughty naughty even though
you have lost your pawn on c2 if your
rook gets really active while
everybody's still at home back here you
know
oops sorry that was a mouse lip just a
second this a second okay overwrite that
rook I I think you're actually doing
really well here and I wouldn't surprise
me at all if you weren't winning in fact
simply because too many weak guys on the
on the first rank there yeah I mean yeah
I would say a good compensation for your
pawn okay you have played Knight d5
takes Bishop c4 and now you've played
efore and now everything's wrong for you
I'm afraid first of all very good move
by him
bravo Bravo b5 he gets in a very nasty
little tempo you didn't have any great
desires to take bishop takes d5 Knight
takes d5 885 when your whole pawn
structure is messed up you drop back
with your Bishop and then essentially
black got to play to move b7 b 5 with
the temple you got to play for free and
instead of being a weakness on b7
it could turn out to be a tower of
strength on b4 you've played Bishop b3
Bishop b3 he has played King e6 and here
I don't like your choice you have played
Bishop b2 I don't like that move at all
this should be too essentially I think
what you have in mind
Gabriel if I can guess is you had maybe
the idea of Bishop b2 Bishop a3 Bishop
takes in mind and here I think you need
to be fighting for more of a of an
equality type of thing you your pawn
structure sucks
okay so you got a remedy your pawn
structure and if I were in your shoes I
would have played f4 here okay so from
my point of view I'm thinking that if
black takes this pawn then my Bishop
emerges like a phoenix and it's just
great on d4 so black is not going to
take that pawn but black has to come up
with a move himself maybe maybe he
should get his King off out of the pin
right maybe something like King d6 takes
Czech tanks now you're obliged to take
take and again I want to do something
that could blast open the bishop on beat
on a one it's just not living a very
good life so I have to play something
with f4 and maybe I have to simply take
here and play f4 so with this idea of f4
in mine what I really want to do is
probably rook g5 so if you take I can go
rook g5 check and end up taking on d4 so
here I think you're struggling for
equality
and a very important lesson in chess is
that when you have weaknesses if you can
trade off your weaknesses with a move
like f4 I would jump on f4 you have
played instead Bishop b2
he played King d6 you've King d6 and now
you have a problem your intention of
Bishop a3 check and takes the knight is
simply going to be met by B 5 B 4 and
it's an oopsie Daisy okay so here I
think you had 2 you're obliged to take
and now your position has a lot of
defects ok hmm even as much as I not a
happy camper
about your position I don't like the
choice you're made here in this case
again you know looking at your Trump's
you don't have too many of them but but
one you definitely have is this Bishop
on d5 and I'm thinking that if you give
bishop on b3 if you give it up for that
knight on d5 it's really really bad news
so here I'm looking at your structure I
don't like anything that I see but but
at least your rook on g1 is kind of
keeping his Bishop honest a little bit I
would have probably played the move h4
here with the idea that that my pawn is
I'm afraid that after he plays a move
like Knight f4 I'm going to be in
positional disaster so I'm thinking that
if in case they Pont Knight comes to f4
my my pawn will be better on h4 and I'm
hoping that if after for example h4 g 6
h 5 i could actually try to turn
something that's a negative into a
positive
not easy another one that you you should
consider here too is the idea that you
could potentially get bishops of
opposite colors and that could be very
useful for you so let me give you
another thought let's say check now it's
clear black moves his king then you're
happy to trade and take so we're going
to oblige black to advance his pawn to
b4 our Bishop has absolutely no business
being on b2 because its biting on
granite so we're going to bring the
bishop to c1 okay now why I just pointed
out this for a moment is let's imagine
black plays the move Knight f4 attacking
our pawn we defend it black plays a move
like g6 to escape the rook aren't being
on g1 here it may not be your beloved
position but here I would say that your
chances of drawing with bishops of
opposite color isn't bad it's a bad it
might be losing but at least bishops of
opposite color gives you potential
Avenue for escape when you've played the
move Bishop takes d5 your position has
no redeemable features yes Julian with
check you mean
of course of course and and very happily
probably he should as well after 95
Bishop here Knight c3 oops now first of
all once more I wouldn't be so eager to
jump into the bishops of opposite color
I would much much rather be trying to
solve the weakness so I I would play f4
with the idea to take on e5 to take on
c3 and get my bishops of opposite color
positions anyway okay
Bishop Edgar 7 yeah Bishop Edgar 7 sure
ok let me get this guy in because why
else did I play h4 if not - if not to
get rid of that guy not rook e8 well
that sure puts the kibosh on my idea of
I'm forced to capture capture with the
b-pawn yeah sure why not right King e2
and I again I'm just hoping I'm putting
blind faith in my bishops of opposite
color position and just hoping that I
can hold it might be very difficult I
have to be aware that in some positions
you may want to sacrifice yeah your
challenge channeling Petrosyan petrosyan
would always want to sacrifice his
exchanges but here there's some there's
some chances for you to save let's go
back back back and instead you have
played oops Bishop takes d5 and after
this I think it's it's hopeless Bishop
takes d5 King takes d5 you main
variation
kingi to g6 very logical move rook a1
Bishop d6 excellent rook a5 rook b8 and
now you are well and truly upon down
King d3 actually he should have played
Bishop c5 right away no because he's
played he's played it in this position
bishop a3 he makes an interesting
decision by going into a straight rook
ending probably it's a good decision I'm
always a little bit leery of straight
rook endings because the defending side
usually has so many chances in a
straight row pending I would have
probably kept the bishop by playing b4
Bishop comes back and fi d4 your
opponent has traded the bishops and
probably he's winning anyway but I would
have probably kept the pieces the
bishops f5 rook a5 here if there's any
chances for you in defending the
position I think it has to lie with
getting your rook as active as possible
I mean it's clear he's going to get the
pawn to e4 but if you could get your
rook down and maybe harass them from
behind you'll increase your chances of
saving the position when you have played
rook a v e4 came with check F tanks F
takes very good move Gabriel King but he
well played you saw that line okay
Group B 6 okay now you now you wised up
here
Bravo rook a 7 you got you so you've
lost a tempo or two okay hmm now here
one of the things I might want to do is
I might want to
this pawn that rook here but the problem
with rook a7 immediately is that after
g5 this rook defends everything the rook
is great
I consider this pawn isolated in week so
I might have played h4 here in
anticipation of rook a H and if you
plays g5 I get rid of one wrinkles you
have played check I believe h6 rook d7
check rook the six good move by him
ooh you traded rooks precisely yeah
you're still seething over your decision
that was a very very bad decision to
trade rooks it's highly unlikely that in
any King upon endgame where there's so
many pawns on the board and your pawn
down that you're able to draw okay
with the rooks your chances are so 99
percent better so trading the rooks I
appreciate that yeah maybe time was a
factor but that's just a you can't do it
right and had you played rook b7 by the
way which I think most players would
have going after this pawn if he defends
the pawn and you play check and if he
you know you're doing your best to
harass him and you know make it as
difficult as possible for black to make
progress but this decision by to trade
rooks nah that's that that's the gong
you know rook takes a new main line King
takes not good d3 so you had some hopes
here I'm not
sure where they might be f3
oops protected passed pawn for b4 yay
for before King e6 it's interesting your
score sheets wrong so you have B for
twice so you have oh maybe it's h4 did
you play h4 yeah ok cool
yeah before before before before King e6
King f3 King f5 uh King g3 the old
breakthrough e - yeah King I like that I
would have made a bishop
it might bought of it yeah King g3 h5 t
takes h5 and that's all she wrote
yeah
right well first of all it was like you
get you you came out of the opening
looking very pretty after Bishop takes
e5 because he fell for that very nice
very nice we haven't even my pleasure
so Julian where's Julian went into the
hall okay well let's see what Julian did
he said black one I mean we're going to
have to talk about his penmanship
I mean J's what is this well first of
all it's funny in the in the good old
days of English descriptive I would
write pawn slash King for pawn to King
four yeah yeah the Old English is a
group it's descriptive later I realized
that algebraic was just so much superior
and I would write pawn to e4 on e4 but
then people told me well you don't have
to use pawns you don't put the pawns in
I'm looking at Julian's notation and he
says pon e4 pawn c5 pani for upon c5
okay then he says Bishop c4 BC for
Bishop c4 and then Natalie Natalie
Bishop c4
jeez I'm going to really need him for my
because Jonathan look at this he goes
night something then it goes Queen f3
move three white plays Queen f3 on move
five white plays Queen f3
do you see move three Queen f3 okay so
so this is like some kind of code you
know you're you yeah well did ya because
otherwise I have a hard time deciphering
so I move three I think the move was
knight c6 and I think white play Queen
f3 and and then instead of playing the
very attractive and very good 95 e six
has been played and then we have the
knight h3 and then we have well hold on
II wait till you get to move five
because whatever Black's next move was
White's fifth move is Queen f3
a julienne well yeah that's what I'm
saying my rights how are you doing
welcome welcome
somebody's playing a dirty trick out
here they say look at Jimmy why why
wouldn't you from funny you should
mention that this is it your game okay
so somebody was having a good good laugh
at your expense